yeah welcome to this video and plain
lovato you laboratorium hmm yeah from
Spain and trying to go for a mainline
route yea big parting of the ways let's
play my my usual repertoire which is
this ancient line of the chi Goren d 598
is the normal continuation yes it looks
very slow and it is slow but it is very
very solid and tough very tough to crack
so is some going for an early own their
form after which my night gets a post
here on e5 mmm yeah should I am just
hack this night off yeah I'll do that
that's a debatable decision but um well
this is very very quickly played also a
bit surprising at least them in my book
okay
the other recapture was interesting as
well yeah okay he doesn't he doesn't
like Queenie six okay what I think is
that I'm excited on the dark squares the
same position seems like em seemed so
fine for black I think so what Bishop to
g5 to f4 this would be enormously
helpful so let's bring let's aim for
that I Quincy fall again yeah this was
bad really bad
I also take care take on edge while 97
was a really crappy mood like absolutely
absolutely bad check wow I need to
suffer him yeah I 97 1 and what had to
read and if you won't probably won't
believe me and tell me I'm I'm trash
talking or whatever but white was
already outplayed them and by quite
quite a margin because he just weakened
the dark squares absolutely deadly and I
don't understand what he's doing okay
let's just take take all the pawns I
just I thought you would just play okay
to at some point and it's just better
yeah I'd take everything check
look look f3m look f3 g3 this would have
been would have been a problem I'm not
saying that this isn't a problem but it
hmm yeah g5 again teague
hmm still enormously tricky g5
is there really no defense against this
I don't see one this cover c8
mcteagues King evade I hope to survive
said it looks a like gently lost
I don't see a window at the moment
maybe this is still still playable it
looked so awful yeah this is Sir this is
funny but it doesn't threaten anything I
think
Queen to d8 if he gives the check check
yeah this isn't exactly funny to play
yeah yeah at one point you will never
look this is just a blunder what time
warning check check check check check
check
white resigned yeah yeah this was whats
am very lucky what the heck did he do
that he can just take g8 and give them
the check this is a mate who create this
is just me yeah this was um just very
difficult to play the [ __ ] compass
looking at the comp evaluation is easy
you should be 8-5 but playing it is
another matter ok I give give this away
and now it got already very tricky like
to take h3 I didn't see that at all can
just take h3 okay and yeah cause the
system made yeah very bad very bad game
but the main thing that status is just
bad as in 97 s is just out of this world
bad 97 how can i play this crap really
of course he replies query for one else
adhere black is in excellent shape
because the dark squares he weakened
them him that's let's let me play
something else let's say here yeah for
example and what is he doing now
fatigues I'm just playing against be too
and the dark squares are terribly weak I
just need to get here for example and
white explodes just a matter of timing
97's not a bad idea it was just timed so
badly here he needs to yeah do some
passive move and then maybe then I can
do that it's a difference
and then I can go here it was just so
idiotic playing it in exactly this spot
because after that I don't have a square
for this piece he he threatens this I
just need to go back and Asha activated
his queen from E to to e6 this is just
an unspeakably bad yeah and after before
black it's just just clearly better
White has this dead bishop I know this
doesn't look great but it can get here
or i can get here while this bishop
theoretically can go here but it's not
easy to accomplish really i really awful
night this heavy and after that i'm
check already in big trouble and here he
can he can just play a normal move or
let's say i'm also this is interesting
if i take we had there's all kinds of
ideas but i thought even even a simple
move like that just is just keeping me
keeping me worse all the time to stir
back problems with those pawns but yeah
very lucky at the end thanks for
watching